[Music]
Republican congressman Matt Gaetz of
Florida has introduced a bill in
Congress that would increase oversight
of the fayette courts the courts that
allow the government to spy on you by
making judges subject to presidential
appointment and Senate confirmation
bringing a little democracy and
transparency to the process
Democratic congressman Adam Schiff of
California may find that bill familiar
to his credit by the way he introduced
the exact same bill verbatim
word-for-word five years ago but
apparently this time he's not eager to
back his own law why is that did his
principles change or just his short-term
political calculations we've invited
congressman Matt Gaetz to join us as
well as former a Hillary Clinton
campaign advisor Richard Goodstein
welcome to you both do you congressman
first it this is word for word the same
bill and tell me if I'm wrong and the
person who wrote the bill is refusing to
support it this time or seems like he
won't why is that it seems odd Tucker
that when Barack Obama was president
Democrats wanted to give the president
more power to work with the Senate to
get members of the FISA Court that
aren't part of the DC swamp but that
come from all over America and have the
opportunity to represent the values that
Americans hold dear regarding their
liberties I didn't change one comma and
Adam ships bill irie filed it because I
think that Republicans and Democrats are
going to be in power in the future and
if there are bipartisan ideas that would
have more transparency and more
oversight and protect our civil
liberties I think we ought to work
together rather than work in separately
so did he send you a thankful text when
you did that you know I asked for him to
co-sponsor it and I just haven't heard
back yet Tucker it's a strange isn't
that Richard would you mind calling him
I mean right by the way I just want to
be totally clear good for Adam Schiff
who might rarely compliment for
introducing this bill in the first place
five years ago it seems like a
common-sense reform of the kind we need
why wouldn't you support it now can I
just remind you why he introduced the
bill this was in light of the Edward
Snowden yeah leaks right there were
thanks to WikiLeaks who were vilified by
Republicans back then and Donald Trump
says I love WikiLeaks on the campaign
trail okay things get twisted in odd
ways you'll have to ask Adam Schiff okay
but it's probably no he wasn't just
vilified by Republicans but also by
Democrats absolutely
is to be fair and and I don't know why
Republicans didn't support it then they
should support an associate everyone how
but honestly how could Adam Schiff who
poses as a man of principle failed to
support his own bill that doesn't make
sense does it again I think the rules of
the Senate have actually changed about
confirming judges so I think you'd have
to ask him I really am NOT here at
little disappointed though you'd have to
be I think you know back then he had Ron
Wyden and Jeff Merkley and other liberal
Democrats so we're supporting the
principle the interest of protecting
individual freedoms so yeah I think
there's still cared about that now I
totally agree so but all of this gets to
the core question in these Dueling memos
Republican and Democrat Nunez and Schiff
get to the question of the FISA warrant
what did the DOJ say in order to spy on
Carter page why can't we see that why
can't we decide for ourselves I should
Tucker and I'm glad that the White House
has joined the call to see more of what
was in this vise application and I think
that we'll be able to see things that
Adam Schiff wrote that are verifiably
untrue and I think that will bolster the
claims that we're making on the
Republican side that there needs to be
reform and there needs to be
accountability for people at the FBI who
withheld the political origins of this
dossier from the court that's the real
problem here there's no dispute that
cash at the DNC was convertible into a
government sponsored warrant to spy on
American citizens and whether you're a
Republican or a Democrat that could
should concern you because it could
happen to any of us that's why we need
to reform and frankly it'd be nice if we
didn't all wrote you know go to our
separate corners politically if we found
some ideas that Republicans or Democrats
had offered that would provide the
transparency and oversight to give the
American people confidence I agree and I
hope Richard and who knows but I really
sincerely hope if the roles were
reversed and the RNC had paid for a
document that some Republican
administration had used to spy on a
rival political campaign that I would be
principled enough to say you know what
that is an abuse of power because it is
why and I'm sure you agree as a civil
libertarian you just said that you were
we should be worried about that so why
shouldn't we see the FISA application
you know I I am a civil libertarian but
I'm more so an American citizen who
cares for kind of the integrity of the
United States and I think what the FBI
was concerned with for
reason I believe is that Carter page was
as they concluded a foreign agent and
and maybe they didn't even know what the
Trump people knew I will say this
the Russians approached one campaign in
one campaign only the Trump campaign I
know he's in the pocket of Putin on
we've heard this but I'm saying but it's
really simple why can't we just see the
face application it's really it's really
this is our government they spotted an
American citizen probably a good reason
perhaps they didn't why can't we know
what you have to ask the the FISA Court
why wouldn't you support that why don't
Democrats say let's end this nonsense
and find out why they did that with the
question of kind of what the relevant
rules are because the FISA is secret by
design but again the fact the matter is
what Schiff said and is unrebutted is
that the dossier had relatively little
role in there was a referent look is
there any support in the Congress for
ending if the Russians want to control
our political process they're doing it
now by paralyzing everything with a
stupid debate which we could end
instantly by making this stuff public is
there support for doing that in your
Congress I believe that there's support
on the Republican side to release the
entire FISA application as long as we're
able to redact sources and methods where
I think we should be able to find
agreement I don't think the Democrats
will want to do that because the dossier
was the lead piece of evidence it's what
every lawyer you know I agree with the
congressman that this should be put out
but again there's no disputing that the
whole investigation proceeded the
dossier being concluded Papadopoulos
without tip of that spear don't know
that let's just find out and then we'll
do a show on it after that maybe we
could not do any Russia until the
Congress releases this and lets the
people decide what they think we can put
this to bed good luck god I'd be for it
both thank you very much